But
even then, we have
to fight the sheer nature of the
web and network architecture.
In this example,
over 50% of the time
from pressing Enter
in the address bar
to the page being displayed is
spent waiting for the answer.
This waiting period is called
Time To First Byte, or TTFB.
If this website needed to
grab additional resources,
we would have to wait for the
response of our first request
before we could send
out a second request.
That in turn means that we have
another period of time waiting
that is not being
used effectively.
This problem is called
head-of-line blocking.
Let's see an example of what
head-of-line blocking is
and how it is bad for
the user experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With HTTP, a connection
is like a queue.
While the first request
is being handled,
all other requests have to
wait until it is their turn.
A lot of time is
being wasted here.
All right, one medium coffee.
Thanks.
Enjoy.
Hey, can I order a drink now?
Yeah, what are you having?
OK, great.
I'd like a venti.
Half whole milk, 1/4 1%,
1/4 nonfat, extra hot,
split quad shot, one
and a half shots decaf,
two and a half shots regular,
no foam latte with whip,
two packets of Splenda,
one Sugar in the Raw,
a touch of vanilla syrup,
and three short sprinkles
of cinnamon.
And I'm kind of in a hurry.
Thanks.
Uh.
Phew.
OK, got it.
While Richard's
drink is being prepared,
the other customers
are left waiting
even though their request
would be much faster to make.
The head of line is blocking
the rest of the customers.
To counteract the
limitation a little bit,
browsers open up to six
parallel connections--
or in our coffee
shop comparison,
they hire another barista.
So while the first connection
is waiting for its first byte,
a second request can already be
sent on the second connection
and so on.
Of course, hiring
a new barista takes
a lot of time and training.
In the browser, opening all
these connections is also
quite costly because of the
TCP handshakes necessary.
The six parallel connections
browsers can make
is still only a band-aid for
the head-of-line blocking.
If you have a lot of
resources on your page,
you will spend most
of your time waiting--
or staring at the cashier.
Head-of-line blocking
is a huge bottleneck
to website performance.
Browsers being able to open
up six parallel connections
help, but it's not great.
Later we'll see how
HTTP/2 fixes issues
with head-of-line blocking.